gentlemen uh it is such a pleasure uh
tracy i want to start with you is it
safe to say
that if there is no eddie murphy there's
no tracy morgan
absolutely the first thing i did on my
first i believe i met eddie on my second
year saturday
night live and when i first met him the
first thing i said to him no lie
i said thank you for holding the door
open for me
and that was it and he grabbed me by my
shoulder and he walked me to this
dressing room
because he was doing the rosie o'donnell
show at that time
and the word came that he was coming
upstairs and
the first time i ever got to meet him
it's like the first time i ever got to
meet wesley i met wesley years ago
and it's still to this to this day is
the same feeling
when you look at that picture that we
took
with uh martin lawrence and wesley and
all of those people do you you've seen
that picture
yeah and will smith and all of us that
picture happened before
years before that there was there's a
picture out there in the world of
richard pryor eddie murphy sydney
portilla bill cosby
and red fox that was that moment all
over again
uh leslie you know what it's like to
deal with
a character that is just so loved going
into this i imagine that there was a ton
of fun
but also the pressure of this is the
thing that people have when they were a
kid that they love and they don't want
anybody to mess with it
talk about that sort of pressure to the
fan base going into this
and you how badly you guys want it to
deliver for the fans
wesley complements can i just answer
this for us
it was all about the first cast they
were there
so they you know the expectations they
were there
and under their gaze under their gaze
we followed those expectations and what
we did we looked at any one of those
those people from the first movie we
looked in their eyes
and we got thumbs up under their gaze
yeah
so i couldn't remember acting eddie x
and eddie
on the last day's shoot are you happy
eddie smiled at me and i knew it from
the side he said i'm happy
and i said i'm happy with happiness i'm
happy for your happiness
we had did our job and then when i first
got to see the movie
i've seen all of us wesley i'm like this
is it
this is it you've seen the movie roz
rock and roll you said
you know what time it is
let me ask you let me ask you this
because i'm curious wesley and i want to
want to know if this happened and what
it felt like when this
when it did happen what is it like in a
moment whether
it's during shooting or offset what is
it like when you make eddie murphy
laugh
it's uh joyful it's like being you know
kids around the block again
you know it reminds you of all days when
you either on the sports or
stoop
[Music]
from the diner like like after the party
street yeah yo yo people yeah he's
iconic but he's just like us
he's just like us it was funny and uh
listen when you got thousands of people
on the set
and you see eddie and wesley standing
right there
in the sea of these people talking to
each other
and making each other laugh guaranteed
all thousands of people are going
i wonder what they talking about it's
like seeing a picture of
robert kennedy and martin luther king
and over office talking
when you see the picture you go i want
to talk about
lord knows what wesley and eddie was
talking about
okay so let me let me ask you this here
because i know i know i know
i i know wesley you've been you've been
asked about this a ton and i want to
come back this now from a fan point of
view which is
tracy morgan how badly do you
want to see wesley snipes as blade again
that's crazy i love the
the first letters so i i love it
i love it i thought it was incredible
you put blade up there
blade is a classic that's a cult classic
and i'm
telling you from a fan's point of view
that's the code classic so you put that
right next to
into the dragon
me my personal wish was to see eddie um
wesley snipes
and jim kelly in the movie
you know that's sir what i mean when i
say jim kelly
is this is this gonna happen wesley is
it gonna happen are we gonna see this
again
are you gonna do it i don't know if i
don't i don't think i'll be playing the
blade character but we got something
else that's coming in the same
family of hybrid hyper action content
and instead of uh
vampires now we're dealing with shape
shifters and a whole lot of other
interesting stuff
yeah so all of that energy that we can
the first blade
when we white belts we're gonna come
back with something there now when both
indigo and chickasaw brown that'll be
you know black belt quality
this was a pleasure uh thank you so much
the movie was fantastic i love both of
you guys
uh and uh take it easy i really
appreciate your time
you